[Applaudissements]
au match frustrant
invaincu depuis le début de la saison
lésigny monteyne ont manqué de réussite
sur cette 5e journée
en première mi-temps les finistériennes
de rose on met la pression et mène
jusqu'à cinq points d'écart entre
minutes pas donc on les laissait
vraiment venir jouer jusqu'à 6 mètres
chance qui nous a fait défaut
les joueuses étaient un petit peu lourde
sur les jeux transition donc on attaque
on faisait pas ce qu'on soit la demande
et ter au départ résultats donc l'équipe
adverse a pris confiance et commencer à
nous faire mal sur le jeu de transition
qui étaient rares
les joueuses de brahim c'est à dire
viennent en seconde mi temps avec un
regain d'énergie et marquent quatre
points sans réponse des adversaires mais
elles ne prendront jamais l'avantagent
on m'aurait savoie un petit pouce
mais en nettement on va vraiment
travaillé pour surpasser ça parce qu'on
n'a pas on a fait beaucoup pour rester
sur du positif en fait c'est qu'on a
fait beaucoup de en attaque c'était pas
ça mais en défense je trouve qu'on était
vraiment là
c'est ce qui va surtout nous aider à pas
tomber moralement on va bien récupérer
ce week-end l'efficacité au tiers sur
tout et ne pas mélanger la précipitation
et la rapidité qui sont deux éléments
complètement différent parce qu'on à
cause de la précipitation on a perdu
beaucoup de ballons en attaque ce qui
est fait que bam façon qui s'enchaînent
lésigny monteyne s'incline 17 à 22 ans
un accroc en ce début de saison
mais elle ne compte pas baisser les bras
elle joue le samedi 9 novembre contre
issy paris
actuellement cinquième au classement